[Music]  they got word  that trouble was coming  the white house are killing the color  barbaric violence was committed against  black people  across this country kerosene  was dropped from an airplane  why did nobody ever teach us this  because they didn't want you to know  when it was an opportunity to wipe out a  community  they took it  i cannot imagine that there are mass  graves somewhere in our community and we  didn't try to find them  they're buried somewhere and the  question is where  we have encountered human remains  it was like they had found people who  had been disappeared by history  the earth had unleashed the truth  we view this as a murder investigation  some people say that city officials  orchestrated  a cover-up  it wasn't a movie it wasn't a chapter in  a book  it happened to real people they burned  the whole  town down but it will rise again